in afghanistan banks are running short
of cash
people can barely afford basics like oil
or rice
and some have gone so far as to sell
their daughters or their organs in order
to feed their families now for one bag
of rice afghans will have to pay to
about 2 900 halfs that's almost 30
a price that is off limits to most
afghans
afghanistan was already one of the
world's poorest countries but since the
taliban take over in august the economy
has collapsed even further and the
country is now facing near universal
poverty
nearly 95 percent of all households
don't have enough food according to the
world food program a crisis exacerbated
by years-long drought as well as the war
in ukraine further pushing up global
prices for grain and food
and sanctions on the taliban have made
it difficult to send money in and out of
the country
this is what a country on the brink of
universal poverty looks like despite
billions of dollars in aid that the
international community has pledged to
afghanistan
in just a year the prices of basic goods
here have risen dramatically take this
bottle of oil its refined sunflower oil
it now costs 850 apps that's about nine
dollars twice as much as it costs last
year one big reason prices have gone up
local currency has lost value making it
hard for businesses to operate the
fluctuation of the currency
is affecting our business because it is
not fixed it is not stable habibullah
amini runs a detergent business in kabul
most of the raw materials he uses for
manufacturing the products he sells in
afghanistan come from outside the
country he says business is down 30
percent since the fall of the u.s backed
republic in august the challenge that we
are facing in our business nowadays is
that importing the raw materials because
we specifically cannot transfer
the tt to the
banks outside of the country because of
the sanctions
although western sanctions don't apply
to businesses sanctions on taliban
rulers mean foreign banks are reluctant
to carry out transactions with
afghanistan
the economic crisis is being felt by
everyone
in recent months some have taken the
drastic decision of selling their organs
dr nasir ahmad conducts transplant
operations in the city of herat for a
kidney he says donors and buyers can
agree on a price that varies between the
equivalent of two thousand to four
thousand dollars
[Music]
foreign
sold his kidney for around two thousand
three hundred dollars
people who do have money in bank
accounts have been lining up outside
banks
many have to wait days or weeks to get
cash out since the central bank's
introduction of withdrawal limits due to
cash shortages
the assets of afghanistan central bank
have been frozen the majority of those
assets or around 7 billion dollars are
on u.s soil
that has made it almost impossible for
the afghan central bank
to prop up the local currency the
afghani which has lost substantial value
afghanistan had long been dependent on
foreign assistance and aid which until
last year funded most of the country's
public spending
in august when the taliban to cover
control of the country foreign financial
assistance which essentially essentially
funded most of the previous government
vanished overnight and even humanitarian
organizations are still struggling to
get money into the country
no country has yet recognized the
taliban as a legitimate government
partly because of their crackdown on
basic freedoms their harsh treatment of
women in particular has drawn criticism
since the taliban took over the country
girls have been banned from secondary
school
and the taliban's decision to restrict
women from work has also had ripple
effects on the country's productivity
levels
a report by the un estimated the loss of
female employment could cost up to one
billion dollars or five percent of the
country's gdp
taliban government says that more than
aid it wants sanctions lifted and the
central bank's frozen assets released in
the meantime it is looking elsewhere to
prop up the economy
afghanistan has witnessed a rise in
public cultivation and the government is
encouraging international investment in
sectors like mining and transit
but a combination of factors is making
it hard to restart the economy we have
had four years of consecutive droughts
in this area we have the legacy of the
conflict of course and but also we have
now a major economic crisis
as the u.s and others way releasing
afghanistan's foreign assets and
international organizations think of
ways to address the country's economic
crisis hundreds of thousands remain
unemployed queues at food distribution
centers stretch on and afghans try to
make ends meet as their economy
continues to spiral